[Music]
hello everybody
a very good morning it is seven o'clock
here in the uk you're very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news this morning and indeed
every morning two big things
in the government's inbox today the
continuing controversy over pingdemonium
and that nhs app forcing lots of us to
self-isolate plus
new measures to stop dangerous channel
crossings by migrants
we'll put those to the home office
minister victoria atkins in just a few
moments time
plus the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy fella wigginer
is also with us this morning also as
kobe cases rise in greece there's fears
that double jabbed holidaymakers
may still have to quarantine when they
return home if it's added to the uk
so-called amber plus we'll speak to the
greek minister for tourism at around
half past seven
and
[Music]
we'll speak to gary kemp the songwriter
and lead guitarist behind the iconic
eighties band spandau ballet
who's attempting to give his solo career
the midas starch see what we did there
it's wednesday the 21st
of july ping pressure questions continue
over the number of people self-isolating
as polls suggest one in five of us has
turned off the nhs app
driving down dangerous crossings britain
and france announced new police patrols
to crack down
on illegal channel migration
mayhem on the metro severe flooding in
china kills at least
12 and forces a hundred thousand to flee
their homes
another extreme weather event as the
climate crisis hits china too
all the latest from tokyo as the
olympics finally get underway but with a
warning from the world health
organization that more needs to be done
to stop the pandemic
by the time the olympic flame is
extinguished
on the 8th of august more than 100 000
more people will perish
extreme heat warnings are in place
across parts of the uk and ireland but
the temperature is expected to remain
above average significantly so by day
and by night and a reminder to take care
in the heat stay away from open water
trapped in a home you can't sell four
years on from grenfell we investigate
why some families are still
suffering by the time this is all
resolved
suddenly i think i will probably be too
old for us to try for a sibling for
blake so it
has entirely impacted our life choices
as a family
[Music]
morning everybody what do you think of
the nhs track and trace
app there's continued confusion and
frustration this morning
over the number of people who are
currently self-isolating
and the rules around it putting many
businesses
under pressure people trapped at home as
we hear news of a potential
new government slogan uh keep life
moving what does that actually mean plus
new polling from yougov has suggested
that one in five
nhs covert 19 app users have contact
tracing
switched off on their app it also found
that one in 10 people who downloaded the
app have
subsequently deleted it and that
one third of people have been avoiding
using it to check in
at venues all that as the head of the
world health organization predicts
more than a hundred thousand people
could die from covid
around the world between now and the end
of the olympic games
we'll be discussing all of that in a
couple of minutes with the home office
minister
victoria atkins so stay tuned for more
on that
but first the other big problem for the
government to solve is
how to stop dangerous illegal migrant
crossings in the channel
news late last night of a deal between
britain and france to
increase french police patrols
and our correspondent jemima walker is
in dover for us this morning hello to
jemima so
what is the news that we're hearing from
pretty patel this morning
so the news that we're hearing from
pretty patel the main news is this deal
between france and the uk that you just
mentioned which
for the uk has a 54 million pound price
tag
what it essentially means is that france
has agreed
to double the number of police
patrolling their borders
to make it much harder for people to
make that crossing across the channel
before it was 100 people now it's gone
up to 200 people
so the intention is that france will be
able to position their police officers
in more places to stop people getting on
those dinghies
and making that extremely dangerous
crossing but the reality is
the border there's that coastline of
france is extremely
vast even with 200 police officers
that's still going to be
an extremely challenging task and we are
still likely to see
lots and lots of people making that
crossing
indeed this year so far we have seen
just over
4 000 sorry 8 452 people making that
crossing
which is more than the entire year last
year so
although the number of people although
the number of people claiming asylum has
dropped
people getting on those dinghies making
that crossing has risen
and we are expecting in the next few
hours to see dinghies coming in
with people on board okay jemima we'll
leave it there for now thanks very much
indeed lots of things to put to the
government minister this morning the
home office minister
victoria atkins is joining us this
morning ms atkins thank you so much
uh for taking the time i know it's
always really busy in the mornings when
you're doing the um rounds of
broadcasters
uh i suppose my first question off the
back of what we were hearing there from
jemima was
should we really be paying the french 54
million quid
to do their jobs properly well good
morning kate and i think the pictures
you've just seen
uh are pictures that people across the
country
are getting increasingly frustrated
about and so we are acting
both at home but also importantly
internationally
to try to tackle this at home just last
night
we were um we passed away sorry we
passed the scrutiny stage of the
uh latest immigration bill to try to
really fix this broken asylum system and
the immigration system that we have
but importantly internationally it's
through agreements such as the one that
the home secretary struck last night
with france
that we will help to control the flow uh
coming over to us so
there was an agreement in november where
we paid for more police officers on
french beaches
we believe that that stopped about seven
and a half thousand people from making
the trip across
and so this deal last night uh will
ensure
with the doubling of police officers on
the beach as well as
uh real improvements in surveillance
technology and other
other matters we really do believe that
this will be part of our solution to
this very very serious problem okay is
it the humanitarian thing to do
to threaten people who are risking their
lives to try to have a better life in
the uk
with four years in jail well is it the
humanitarian thing to do to allow
people smugglers criminal gangs to
exploit
people uh to bring them over in boats
that are
simply not seaworthy i mean i've seen
for myself some of the
um dinghies that they're bringing many
many people over across the channel one
of the busiest well the busiest shipping
route in the world
and the huge risk to life that that
presents
so we're trying as i say to ensure that
we have an immigration system that is
firm but fair that we are opening up
safe
routes for people to come legally
through but also
cracking down on these criminal gangs
that are exploiting people's wishes
to come to this country yeah as you say
they're getting on these flimsy dinghies
because
they're prepared to risk their lives
because they want to move from the
countries where their lives are
at risk let alone the busiest shipping
lane in the world and all of the
challenges that that
causes and we're now saying if you
manage to do all of that
we're still going to put you in jail for
up to four years but the
important thing and i don't accept the
um proposition of your question but just
just taking a step back if someone is
seeking asylum
and they have come from a country a
conflict-ridden country
then by definition to get on that small
boat
they will have passed through at least
one safe country
france germany and so on we've only to
see
the you know the movement patterns
across the eu towards
uh the french beaches the and then the
boats coming across to see that people
don't seem to be taking up the
opportunity to
uh claim asylum and seek safety in other
eu
countries in the eu that are perfectly
safe so that's
that's the message we've really got to
land with people that if you're if
you're landing
in the eu it's a safe um a set of
countries of course it is
please that is where you should be
seeking asylum
okay so don't come to the uk at all well
we have we will have open and uh safe
routes for people to come legally so we
have a proud record
of welcoming refugees from some of the
most conflicted
areas of the world uh we have welcomed
tens of thousands of people
over recent years uh we have programs to
help unaccompanied asylum seeking
children as well we take that very
seriously
um but we our message must be please you
cannot come to
this uh country illegally but because
apart from anything else
it's not fair on the people who are uh
trying to enter this country
legally who are playing by the rules and
uh and we welcome them with open arms
okay let's talk to me about apparently a
new slogan that the government is
launching called keep
life moving uh a new government slogan
to deal with covid19 and its aftermath
what does that actually mean
okay you'll have to forgive me i'm not a
health minister so i haven't heard that
phrase before
you've just used it now but what i do
know is that we're all really focused on
trying to
ensure that at this in this stage of the
pandemic as we're easing the
restrictions
that we're doing so in a way that is
safe and secure because sadly
on the way out let me ask you about the
test and trace uh
app which you will know quite a lot
about um
is it really fit for purpose it looks so
people according to the latest yougov
poll
uh 20 percent of people have just
switched it off and another third have
deleted it all together
we don't have those figures within the
system itself we know
in fact that um people hundreds of
thousands of people have joined it
recently and i think in terms of the app
itself look i know
it's frustrating when people have been
pinged and they have to
self-isolate if they've been in contact
with someone who has covered
um and i really do understand the
pressures that this is placing on people
and on businesses
um but we we're now in this new stage of
our
um solutions for the pandemic and
the uh test and trace app is one of the
key tools that we have
isolation is one of the key tools we
have to try to slow the spread
of this violence look we've got the the
vaccine that that has been an
absolute game changer but we
okay we've got so much to talk about so
let's counter through if i may i mean
we i was chatting to michael o'leary
earlier this week you know who he is of
course uh ryanair chief exec
he advised our viewers to completely
delete the app because it was pointless
i was speaking to a personal trainer
yesterday
and he said a lot of people in the gym
had put their phones in their lockers
while they worked out they were all
pinged
yes well i'm i'm not normally in the
habit of accepting mr o'leary's advice
and i'm not going to change
today um our very clear advice uh from
scientists is that self-isolation is one
of the key ways that we will manage
the pandemic look we all want to get out
of the restrictions we do you know
we want to try to get back to life as
normal as possible over the coming
months we've eased the restrictions this
week
we're asking people to take
responsibility
to use their personal judgments and the
app
and the test and trace system as a whole
is one of the ways in which we managed
this pandemic
i mean i think the ons has said that um
if you are in contact uh with
a person who is positive something like
a third of people who've been in contact
go on themselves to develop covert we
know that you're
about five times more likely to come
down with covert if you've been in that
close personal contact with someone who
has tested positive
so it's really just about trying to
manage the risk of positive
okay why doesn't the government give us
a list of key workers like you did last
march a year last march people that
could still go to work when there was a
lockdown the first lockdown in the
united kingdom why don't we have a list
of critical workers
so that is being worked on at the moment
i understand we made an
announcement on monday about certain
people who work for the nhs and um
in the care sector uh but uh we are that
a list of such workers is being
worked on because again we do we have
been listening we do understand
the implications that this is having for
certain yeah you're saying being worked
on
but you know we know that 1.7 million
people that's reported
have been pinged and are self-isolated
when you say being worked on it's not
that difficult given that you've already
had a list that you were working with
last march why don't you just say
let's put that back into place again so
you know uh bin men
can be exempt nursery and teaching staff
social workers
the justice system religious staff
journalists
why not well um just but
in the professions that you've just
listed there you can see how
suddenly the numbers are expanding and
so it is it's a different exercise from
the exercise of last year
uh in terms of key workers who can
return to their place of work
it's a slightly different exercise
because where the scientists will have
to be con
calculating you know how many people
equals
uh risks in terms of um spreading the
uh spreading the virus around the
country so it is a it's a complicated
exercise but it is very much being
worked on as i say we made the first
step this week
uh with our announcement in relation to
the nhs to that end there's a story in
the guardian newspaper this morning
that border officials will no longer be
required to make basic covey checks on
arrivals
in england from green and amber list
countries
there'll be no need necessarily for
people to say where they will be
um isolating for their five or ten days
and there'll be no need for them to
prove on every occasion
when they're going to have their tests
is that government policy
i haven't been briefed on that so i i
that that's again
uh not my portfolio area but what i do
know is that we
are uh applying the quality isn't it
border control is part of your remit no
border control part of your remit no
horrible hidden
harm so i've actually come on the
program to talk about violence against
women and girls
and we're going to talk about that but
you're the government minister
representing the government's policy
this morning
so if you could just uh offer me a view
on that it is in the papers this morning
i'm sure you had a look at them before
you came on
a specialist minister in those areas but
in terms of quarantine rules
we have again on monday we set out that
if you've been double vaccinated there
are changes in relation to ambulance
countries
and of course with redless countries
those rules still very much apply you
must not travel there
so it's not something that the
government would support loosening the
restrictions on ambulance countries
people coming in from those countries
into the uk whether it's from
france spain potentially spain or other
countries
with other countries there are i
understand a series of agreements that
have been set up
to ensure that vaccines overseas are
recognized
here and vice versa so you know there's
a lot of work that goes on behind the
scenes to try to ensure that
international travel can continue albeit
in a very very different way from
how we've understood it in years
previously as you said you
also want to talk about uh violence
against women and girls this morning
again reading in the papers a third of
universities are using gagging
clauses to prevent students speaking out
about sexual assault what's your advice
on that
well we've today we're launching the
tackling violence against women and
girls strategy which is a radical
cross-government strategy to tackle
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls
we know from the national conversation
that
flared up earlier this year following
very very tragic events
just how much uh women and girls are
experiencing and have experienced in the
past
in terms of those sorts of crimes we
absolutely want to tackle them
these crimes are not inevitable and so
this document is a
huge document across as i say all
aspects of
national and local life in terms of
education we very much want to
work with education to ensure that we're
teaching
girls and boys really good healthy
attitudes in terms of relationships and
how
they're treating each other but also in
university we do
we're very concerned about allegations
of sexual harassment within universities
we want to ensure that universities
are uh have a consistency and a quality
of standards that they're applying and
we are very looking very carefully at
this use of
ndas in some universities because we are
concerned about
how they could be used to cover up very
very harmful practices within
universities
yeah let's stick with the subject of
women
how powerful is um carrie johnson
a supportive spouse as some would see
her or a shadowy
lady macbeth figure as she was seen
yesterday running the country while her
husband
uh doesn't know how to do it i think mrs
johnson is
um married to the prime minister and
she's a person in her own right
i feel very uncomfortable when we tell
some people delve into descriptions such
as the one you've you've just used
she's a professional woman in her own
right she happens to be married to the
prime minister
and i think we should um just let her
get on with the job of
being married to the prime minister
frankly yeah but does that include
helping run the country no i mean number
10 have been
clear that uh some of the allegations
that were made in last night's interview
um that political appointments for
example are a matter solely for the
prime minister
um but i i don't know carrie but i know
friends who i have friend dear friends
who are friends with her and i know that
she is a
supportive wife as frankly every other
spouse of a prime minister has been
um i wonder if mr may got asked these
questions
you know that was the question i was
about to put to you and the fact that
you know do we treat
spouses that are women different to
spices that are men
well um having had the um
real privilege of not one but two female
prime ministers we're the only
uh party that has uh enabled that to
happen um i i think it's fair to say
that
uh well people will judge themselves if
there has been a difference in the
treatment between
the husbands of prime ministers as
opposed to the wives of prime ministers
indeed so um thanks a lot for taking the
time i know you're a busy lady so we'll
let you go thanks a lot
much thanks i want to show you we showed
you those pictures didn't we about what
was happening in china severe floods
have killed at least 12 people
and forced thousands to flee their homes
with metro networks
plunged underwater our asia
correspondent tom cheshire is in beijing
for us uh
tom those pictures on the metro goodness
yeah i mean it's been a really wet
summer here all across china but what
happened in hernan province in the
centre of china was another level
weather forecasters said
these were once in a thousand years rain
and they bought
terrifying consequences here's our
report
people were making their way back home
after work when the water burst in
it happened so fast that the trains were
still running
inside the carriages commuters were
trapped and what started as an
inconvenience
quickly became the stuff of nightmares
the trains stopped
the water rising up to the next and
nothing they could do
but wait and hope graphic videos on
chinese social media
showed apparently lifeless bodies in the
carriages and on the station platforms
cataclysm on an ordinary commute
this man is saying that hundreds of
people are trapped
and at least some of them were rescued
hernan province is home to nearly a
hundred million people
it has been hit by heavy rain since the
weekend
but nearly a year's worth fell in just
one day on the provincial capital of
zhengzhou yesterday
that's more than felon cologne in
germany with all the devastation
that brought it is the rainy season here
but the ferocity of the flooding took
everyone by surprise across the city
dozens of vehicles were swept away made
to look like toy cars floating in the
water
foreign a huge rescue operation was in
place
and chinese state media reported that a
hundred thousand people have been moved
to safety
more than 150 students and teachers were
trapped
at this kindergarten the army warned
that major dams could burst
wreaking more havoc and it is still
raining this has already been a week of
climate disasters
wildfire in the us catastrophic flooding
in europe
now china too there is no place on this
planet that will go
untouched
the official death toll currently stands
at 12 but looking at those pictures you
would expect that to rise the chinese
president xi jinping
has said uh warned of heavy casualties
and said this is a severe situation
the fact that he's already made a
statement shows that the leadership is
taking control there are five
soldiers being dispatched to hernan to
try and clear this up and it does look
like the waters are receding
but i think after that has happened
people are going to be asking quite
rightly how was the city uh
able to be taken by such surprise by
these waters yes
okay tom absolutely horrific pictures
thanks so much for updating us
appreciate it thank you
um i also want to tell you what's
happening in the united states talking
about extreme
weather and uh what happens as a result
look at this
more than two 000 firefighters are
currently tackling the so-called
bootleg fire in the u.s state of
oregon it's the largest wildfire so far
this year in the united states having
already burned
more than 364 000 acres of land
the flames have grown by around four
miles every day for the last fortnight
due to gusty winds and dry hot weather
something that's expected to continue
over the coming days
and these dramatic pictures the fire is
now so large that it can actually be
seen
as they say from space
my goodness we're going to be talking
about the extreme weather here in the
united kingdom with kirsty in just a
short while
uh too but before that i want to tell
you about covid
cases and uh the rise in greece there's
fears double jabbed holiday makers may
still have to quarantine
when they return home if it's added to
the uk so-called amber
plus list we'll speak to the greek
minister for tourism
in about five minutes top of the next
hour we'll speak to the shadow foreign
secretary lisa nandy
with labor claiming the government's
building safety bill will only make the
situation worse for leaseholders
and then at 20 past eight we'll speak to
the royal national
lifeboat association institute isn't it
about how to stay
safe at the beach and on the sea while
enjoying
the hot weather so many people losing
their lives
when they are out swimming in waters
that they don't know
don't do that the rnli will be telling
us a little bit more about how to keep
safe
some other stories though making news
for you this morning
and marcus rashford has criticized a
spectator magazine
ahead of an article set to be published
suggesting that he was
a benefiting commercially from his
campaigning the
england player said he partnered with
brands to progress the work i do
off the pitch and ask why footballers
can't just do the right thing
harvey weinstein has been extradited to
california to face further sexual
assault charges
the former hollywood producer was
convicted and sentenced to 23
years in prison in new york last year
for rape and sexual assault
he lost a bid to block his move to
california and now faces trial in los
angeles
on charges of allegedly attacking five
women between 2004
and 2013.
ministers are preparing to outline their
proposals to parliament for solving the
problems caused by the northern ireland
protocol
yesterday boris johnson spoke to his
dublin counterpart urging pragmatism
in order to mend the issues being
created by the post-brexit terms
newspaper reports suggest brexit
minister lord frost
will outline a strategy that will look
to get rid of most checks on goods
traveling between great britain
and northern ireland
russian state officials have released
footage of the mansion of a traffic
police officer who they said led a
criminal gang extorting
huge bribes the mansion fit with
gordy decorations a billiard hall gilded
columns
and even a gold toilet they pay well
don't they is one of 80 properties
raided by police with
35 people arrested russia's
investigative committee said the
criminal group had received bribes with
a total of
19 million rubles that's just
under 190 000
pounds how many traffic cops here in the
united kingdom have a home
like that to call their own as i was
saying really really wild weather
at the moment all around the world not
least here in the united kingdom kirsty
is standing by for us hi kirsty
good morning keith yes it's summer in
the uk so we might expect it to get
quite hot
but it's really hot at the moment
uncomfortably so especially by night and
by day
so the met office has got its first ever
extreme heat warnings in fourth
time for some details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning very hot and sunny weather
is set to continue
changing is coming for the weekend but
for now we really are focusing on the
heat
the met office has extreme heat warnings
in force
mainly for parts of south wales the
midlands southern and southwest england
and northern ireland so for the next
couple of days into friday for northern
ireland
we're looking at very high temperatures
by day and by night
and that could lead to some adverse
health effects and of course a lot of
warnings associated with a high
temperature when you're trying to stay
cool
stay away from open water and other
things like that you've just got to play
it safe at the moment
temperatures rising very quickly then
this morning in that strong summer
sunshine high uv levels
so a real risk of sunburn at the moment
a little bit of cloud hugging those
north sea coast but
it will be brightening up through the
day and maybe the far north and northern
i'll sting rather gray
but otherwise in the sunshine high
temperatures widely high 20s into the
low 30s up to 32 celsius
90 fahrenheit there is a small chance of
a shower popping up today maybe eastern
england for example you can see the blue
there
but those will be few and far between
and i think a smaller chance of thunder
shower compared to
yesterday tonight it is going to be a
very warm and
muggy night temperatures in some places
could stay above 20 celsius
and that would mean it's a tropical
night certainly an uncomfortable night
for sleeping
tomorrow we do all over again low cloud
burning back to the coast in the north
and east
hot and sunny small chance of a
the shower sponsored by qatar airways
yeah pretty warm here in the studio as
well this one is 22 degrees this morning
when i got in the car so
be aware of that if you are heading out
today take a look at the most recent
coronavirus figures as well
from the uk here we go nearly a hundred
more people
have died from covid19 the highest
figure since the end
of march uh 46 505
58 new cases of coronavirus 96 more
deaths were reported
in the last 24 hours that takes the
total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test to
almost 129 000
more than 35 000 first doses of a covey
jab were given
in the 24 hours and more the last 24
hours
and more than 143 000 second doses
more than 36 almost 36 and a quarter
million people are now fully vaccinated
against the virus
well the vaccination program continues
to reduce the proportion of infected
people admitted to hospital
and the numbers dying the ratio of
hospitalizations to cases
has been cut by around two-thirds
compared to the winter wave
and deaths from a given number of cases
are now almost
10 times lower there's a continued
confusion
and frustration this morning over the
number of people who are currently
self-isolating
and the rules around it putting many
businesses under pressure
the home office minister vicky atkins
told me earlier that people should not
turn off the app
as isolation is one of the key tools the
government still has
in the pandemic our very clear advice uh
from scientists is that self-isolation
is one of the key ways that we will
manage
the pandemic look we all want to get out
of the restrictions we do you know
we want to try to get back to life as
normal as possible over the coming
months we've eased the restrictions this
week
we're asking people to take
responsibility to use their personal
judgments
and the app and the test and trace
system as a whole
is one of the ways in which we managed
this pandemic
political correspondent tomorrow cohen
is um at home
this morning few little issues haven't
we as far as kovit is concerned i'm sure
everything
will be fine that's all our viewers need
to know this morning but uh talk to me
what you what you heard from the
minister
hoping to be back with you in the studio
cnk yes victoria atkins
responding rather angrily to michael
o'leary
at the head of ryanair suggested
yesterday that people should just turn
the app
off not sure whether that's what he
advises his staff to do but she said
that despite the frustrations everyone's
feeling with this pandemic
of course a million children off school
at the moment and
um who knows how many more people are
off work because
of being pinged by the app she said that
although it is not the law it is uh
guidance as the government said
yesterday uh it is
so important that people self-isolate
because you're far more likely to get
covered if you have been
in contact with someone who has so she's
saying
please bear with us until mid-august
when uh the rules will change on that
um interesting kay that over the last
few weeks has been suggestions by
ministers that they wanted to look at
the sensitivity of the app that seems to
be off the agenda now they're just
saying
please stick with it even though it
might be a nightmare over the next few
weeks
yeah um two-year-old blake and his
parents
have reached the limits of their small
flat but his mum vicky
can't sell because of fire risks
identified in the block
which could cost them forty thousand
pounds to fix while they wait to find
out
the chance to have another child is
slipping away too
sadly both my husband and i have been
diagnosed with depression
we're both on antidepressants and both
been suffering with anxiety
we are well and truly stuck we can't
move and
by the time this is all resolved sadly i
think i will probably be too old for us
to try for a sibling for blake so it
has entirely impacted our life choices
as a family
these flats in birmingham don't have
flammable cladding like grenfell
tower but problems with insulation fire
breaks
and timber balconies in the same block
is tom who bought a flat here with money
he inherited when his mother died
he fears it's now worthless we've got
the waking watch
who were walking around the building 24
7 basically to ensure
that it's not on fire um and they're a
constant reminder that the building has
been deemed
to be unsafe um and and the wake and
watch are also costing us five thousand
pounds a week as well across the
development so
there's a lot of financial cost and
there's a lot of kind of mental cost as
well
others caught up in the cladding crisis
came to protest outside downing street
my uh kind of anticipated bill is like
to be in the region of
70 000 or more we tried to move a couple
of years ago but obviously
it was just before this happened and
then this happened
we're not asking for the government to
pay we're asking the developers to pay
and actually need to legislate to make
sure the developers pay
these lease holders from across the
country are in the same situation
trapped in flats deemed a fire risk the
government has promised help
but not everyone will get it the
government have put five billion pounds
into the removal of dangerous cladding
but some conservative mps say they'll
push for more
when a new law is debated in parliament
we will definitely be laying amendments
and doing everything we can
working across party with anybody to
actually ensure that these holders get
some kind of protection at the moment
there's five
million people pretty much affected by
what's going
on and this is of the government's own
making the developer of these flats red
row
told us they're aware of the stress
residents are under due to new
government standards
and they're taking up what they say are
unproven defects
with the firm that built it meanwhile
families here
feeling constant alert
well that is my report about how four
years on from the grenfell tower tragedy
we've still got hundreds of thousands of
people
caught up in this fire safety problem
where their flats have been deemed
unsafe
but they're not sure whether they're
going to be covered by the government
schemes to remove
dangerous cladding because they may have
dangerous insulation or a host of
other fire safety problems mps are going
to be debating this
in the house of commons this afternoon
and a number of conservatives as we just
saw there
think that the government's measures
don't go far enough uh yeah chatting to
justice
for grenfell representative a little bit
later on just before i let you go though
um samara what did you make of what the
government minister was saying
in defense of carrie johnson
yes well this is the interview with
dominic cummings which aired last night
and uh pretty much bombshell after
bombshell as we've become used to
since his spectacular falling out with
the prime minister
one thing that he said in that interview
was that
he was essentially painting carrie
johnson the prime minister's wife has
the power behind the throne saying she
wanted to
get rid of him and all the other
advisers
um you got the sense from victoria
atkins there that she said she was very
uncomfortable
with that language that she thought it
came across as very uh
dismissive of of mrs johnson's role as a
professional
uh in her own right and that um
suggesting that uh
she is to blame for some of the
government's woes was it was deeply
unfair
by by dominic cummings it must be said
um although
um tory mps have been out in force
suggesting that dominic cummings has
uh only damaged himself uh with with
this interview
uh downing street have uh yesterday um
disputed a number of the claims that he
makes okay for now tomorrow thanks so
much indeed
thanks a lot um been considerable doubt
over whether the olympics
should be going ahead amid rising covic
cases
in tokyo the games have actually started
this morning the opening ceremony
is on friday uh some events including
softball
are already underway um our sports
correspondent
tom parmenter is in tokyo for us he's
going to be updating us
every morning on what's happening at the
games uh starting this morning with some
breaking news tom i believe
yes unfortunately it's another athlete
who has tested positive we've just heard
the last few minutes that
a dutch skateboarder 31 year old candy
jacobs is the latest athlete to test
positive
in the athletes village itself and that
brings to six now the
number of positive cases in that village
which was supposed to be this ultra safe
bubble within the games well
the cases unfortunately keep coming
we've heard also of a chilean taekwondo
player who's had to withdraw from the
games due to a positive
covid test and this is the kind of
disruption that the organizers were
bracing for
and is now materializing we've also
heard from
the world health organization dr tedros
familiar face
around through the 18 months of the
pandemic
he's been here in tokyo talking to the
olympic organizers and
just reminding everyone really that the
pandemic is far from over around the
world
the pandemic is a test
and the world is failing
more than four million people have died
and more continue to die by the time the
olympic flame
is extinguished on the 8th of august
more than 100 000 more people will
perish
my sense is that it would be
extraordinary
if a british athlete tested positive
coming into the olympic environment
primarily because
outside of this our testing protocols
are significant that's not to say that
it is a guarantee
and that's why absolutely everybody is
on a daily basis is working really
really hard to make sure
that that does not happen
the pandemic will always be there in the
background it's a bit of a tightrope
these games but
of course we're here to celebrate great
moments of sport and hopefully
show you some extraordinary things that
some these athletes have been training
five years now since the last olympic
games in rio
let's take a look now at some of the
runners and riders who are the big metal
hopes for team gb
in tokyo 2020
there's 175 men on team gb
but 200 women
remember the name caroline dubois aged
11
she had to choose a boy's name just to
get inside a gym
i said my name was colin and i was there
for like about six months
i think there's nothing more that i like
doing than proving people wrong
you know people say you can't do this it
just makes me angry and makes me want to
say
okay let me show you that i can
also watch out on the boxing team for
lauren price from ponte pool
and lower stuffed mum-of-three charlie
davison
look out for the blue hair of sinead
macintosh from edinburgh she's our first
shot at a medal
laura muir and keeley hodgkinson are
middle distance medal prospects
and dina asher smith goes for gold in
the 100 meters
200 meters and four by 100 relay
in equestrian charlotte de jardin goes
for her third consecutive gold
so too helen glover in rowing and jay
jones in taekwondo
there's also track cyclist royalty laura
kenny
it makes me proud that i can sit amongst
some of the best female athletes
and be part of that movement that is
currently happening
and it's not even just as a female as a
mum as well
ready set
liam heath won gold last time and those
arms haven't lost their strength
every athlete knows that their
meticulous planning and training could
be disrupted at
any point through the olympics by a
coveted alert
or a positive test that is the tight
rope
of the tokyo games adam petey is hot
favorite again
andy murray is back and watch for max
whitlock in gymnastics
in triathlon johnny brownlee goes alone
his older brother alastair
hasn't qualified this time and then
there's skye brown
just 13 years old but in with a genuine
shot at a medal
as skateboarding makes its debut these
games will surprise us
kovid may disrupt things but team gb is
here
and they are ready to chase down their
dreams
tom parmenter sky news
so the games have now begun softball is
underway up in fukushima we have the
team gb women's football
kicking off in less than an hour okay it
is getting very real now here in tokyo
okay thanks for the update
john thanks a lot as i said tom in tokyo
throughout the course
of the games now as kobe cases continue
to rise in holiday hot spots such as
greece and spain
there's fears that double-jabbed
holidaymakers may still have to
quarantine
when they return home if the countries
are added to the uk so-called
amber plus list joined by the greek
tourism minister harry theo harris hello
to you it's always great to see you
thanks for joining us
how concerned are you that it that your
country may be added
to the um list which means that people
who are holidaying from the uk
will have to isolate when they come home
well we always know that this is going
to be
a summer where we have to monitor
everything it's a very dynamic
situation first of all we welcome the
british tourist decision by the uk
government to allow
on amber list countries if you're
vaccinated to come back without a
quarantine
but of course this is subject to review
we are have established
and worked hard to show to the british
government how meticulous how
professional our system is
and to provide all the data necessary
for them to make informed decisions
that's effectively all that we would ask
them so what
do brits need to know about what to do
when they travel to greece
well um things have not changed
much since you know perhaps the last
time that we
talked protocols are still in place
we have recently opened indoor spaces
those spaces are only accessible to
vaccinated
people only but of course there are a
lot of outdoor spaces
in restaurants etc that everyone can can
enjoy and share
other than that we ask everyone to
follow the protocols and
the health and safety there is no mask
wearing outside
except in crowded places say a small
alley or
places where many people are outside and
we advise caution um and of course
the mask wearing is required in indoor
spaces
um no music on mykonos is that right
this is for a few days we wanted to
ensure
that we make the right decision to
protect everyone's
health um i was asked
only recently one of us in london
whether we're gonna
still keep the health and safety as our
number one priority or
economic interest might take precedence
i think we're showing
that we're not afraid to make the right
decisions for the health and safety
of our visitors and of our citizens so
this is what we will continue to be
doing
all throughout the summer in order to
ensure that everyone is safe
do you fear that tourism is
uh driving the increase in kobe cases in
greece
uh no we don't we don't see that we
don't see that
there's a high incidence at our borders
our
rates are only 0.01 up to 0.09
in the previous days so we don't see a
high incidence in the
people coming at our airports or at our
land quarters
um but the increase in mobility in the
summer and also the the
the delta variant which spreads uh very
very quickly
has uh increased a number of cases uh
throughout europe this is not just about
the
southern countries or the touristy
countries this is about every country
and at the same time i think we're
seeing that a lot of
um cases are registered
but not a lot of pressure in the health
system we hope that this will continue
being the case
of course greece is a country that has
an extensive testing program we were the
first country to provide free testing
at home and we have um uh you know a
very big number certainly one of the
highest numbers in europe in terms of
testing
and uh this um helps isolate people but
also drives up
the number of cases at the same time a
very quick uh thought before i let you
go what would you say to our transport
secretary who might be considering
putting your country
on a different list
we we certainly hope that the data
supports our view that we should remain
on the amber list greece is a safe
country we have
innovated our vaccination drive and
program continues
unabated our numbers are comparable to
the uk numbers that i saw you were
presenting uh before
um more than 55 close to 60
of the adult population has been
vaccinated
so this is uh all in all uh we we
innovate we provide for the young people
150
euros different if they get vaccinated
um
and so so that we we try to do
everything we can to help
um keep keep the situation under control
and we certainly feel that it is under
control
okay minister always a pleasure thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you
so from athens who fancy's going to the
beach
okay let's take you to the spanish city
of marbella joined
by journalist john clark who looks after
one of the uh
local newspapers the olive press there
it's always great to see you uh john
thanks for joining us this morning
what's the mood in spain as
uh cases are continuing to rise there
okay good morning well uh it's
everyone's very happy here that finally
the brits are coming back
as uh you know we used to have 80
million of you guys coming over every
year and uh
last year i think we might have had a
million perhaps tops so uh
it's it's great to have them back now
we've been getting
tourism dribbling in from germany a bit
from france uh
some from scandinavia and but you don't
really notice the heavy amounts of
tourism
i've been flying in and out a few times
from the islands recently on work
and indeed from germany and italy and
going through the airports is very quiet
it's an easy process people are really
respectful
of the rules here everyone's wearing
masks on buses public transports
restaurants and although the infection
rates creeping up a bit yes that's true
the delta
seems to be the predominant variance at
the moment
there's no stress in the hospitals at
the moment and
people seem to be you know careful and
uh you know if there's no concerns in in
in the hospitals then
we're not over concerned at the moment
so we're very grateful to be on the
ambulance and i hope we stay that way
yeah although looking at the figures
john it looks as though
the figures uh for the islands are
almost double those for the mainland and
one can only assume that that's being
driven by uk tourists who are bringing
um
covered with them
well first of all okay it's not uh uk
tourists entirely because
you've got a lot of tourists coming in
from other parts of the world
and yes that's true the rates have gone
up and
indeed they've doubled they've gone up
on the mainland as well i think we're
around 500 now
or 600 but um despite the
the rates going up the the key here is
the health service and you know it's
mostly young people who are catching it
let's face it everyone over 40 here is
double vaccinated i think it's around
coming up for 60 percent of the adult
population is double vaccinated
and you know mostly people in the 30s
now getting vaccinated so
it's young people who are fighting this
off you know they get a little bit of a
headache and snotty nose you know my
daughter had it recently
they just just pass it off really um
just before
i let you go john indulge my viewers if
you would with a beautiful view of
what's behind you there if you wouldn't
mind
there you go not pushed me off the
screen this time okay i'm not no i'm not
but it looks
amazing i'd love to dip my toe in that
water
thanks very much indeed john appreciate
it hopefully and we'll speak again soon
thank you
you're welcome thanks a lot uh
check out these pictures um in australia
we're going right around the globe this
morning aren't we
a man has been arrested after making a
dramatic escape using bed sheets
to abseil down from his quarantine hotel
that's exactly what he did after
arriving in perth on a flight from
brisbane
he had his application for entry refused
and was told to quarantine
for 48 hours that's all before uh
leaving the state but instead he decided
to escape
making his descent from his fourth floor
room using a rope
made out of bed sheets eventually he was
caught and arrested by officers
around eight hours later i mean it's
fairly obvious which room they were
coming from so
fairly obvious who was responsible there
we are
so he's been arrested now returning to
the new deal britain has agreed with
france
aimed at stemming the rising number of
migrants crossing the english
channel joined now by the former
director general of the uk
border force and that's tony smith hello
to you mr smith thanks for joining us
on the programme this morning what are
you making of what we've heard overnight
about
uh what pretty patel is planning
uh morning k well i'm not surprised that
we're investing in more border security
in northern france because
you know the game of cat and mouse going
on on the french coast between the
french
border police and the smuggling gangs
and it's pretty clear that um
smuggling gangs have got a lot of
resources they're moving migrants along
the coast we're seeing different points
of disembarkation so by providing the
french with
more resources more patrols and
potentially more technology to track and
trace
the smuggling gangs it gives us a
greater opportunity to
uh prevent these um to prevent these
crossings and of course ultimately to
save lives
amnesty international of course disagree
they say the plans are extremely
reckless
and a dangerous response
yes well there's always going to be
widespread political opinion on this i
mean i think what the government are
trying to do
here is to tackle the international
smuggling ring
rings that are operating across the
channel k and um that is very very
dangerous
um activity uh we we will see we have
seen drownings we will see
more we've had a very nice weather
window haven't we the last few days
which has enabled a very large number to
come which has
pushed this back in the public eye um
but the problem we have is that there's
a vicious circle really the migrants are
being
told well if you give us 5 000 10
thousand euros just jump into this
dinghy
you know we'll get you on the water and
you know you will achieve your ambition
to get into the uk and because we're not
returning anybody
who are coming um you know on this route
then obviously that's working and so
more will come
so i think it's a real attempt now to
try and work with the french to break
that
uh cycle and to try and put these
smuggling gangs out of business
um on the wider topic of border control
a report in this morning's guardian
newspaper
um suggesting that border officials no
longer require to make basic covered
checks on arrival into the uk from amber
list
countries um thoughts on that
well okay so the covid checks at the
border have
caused huge problems for our officers
certainly in the early stages where
there was a manual process passengers
were having to print paperwork
show us their ipads and iphones where
the batteries have gone flat seven hour
delays
a lot of work going on now to firstly
require the airlines to do those checks
before you board
so a lot of people will have been
checked by the airline anyway before you
arrive at the uk
and secondly to upgrade our e-gates so
that we can cross-match your
health records with their own with our
own system with your passport
uh number so there's a lot work going on
and it's quite a complicated
solution but a problem for the border
forces of course you know they have to
implement
regulations laid down by government our
job is to protect
health and to stop new variants of covid
getting into the country
so they're going to kind of continue to
try and do that but they're trying to
use technology and
a slightly different risk assessment
framework to enable us to do that and
keep the passengers
moving as best we can while you know
undertaking our statutory duties
um what's your thoughts on the query
about whether border staff should be
uh still listed as critical workers
meaning that
um if they're pinged they can still go
to work
well i think they should because they're
front line operational officers and they
don't just work at the airport of course
you know we we discussed um you know the
migrant boats
we've got border force officers and
immigration enforcement officers
putting themselves at risk every day to
to deal with migrants
crossing we are front lines so i do
think that the border force
are in the same category as as other
essential workers to keep our borders
open to secure our borders
and also you know to protect the health
of the of the country and
people coming in and out of the country
so i i i do think that that is an
important factor
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us this morning thanks a lot
a lot to talk about in the next hour uh
including the
nhs app uh government's saying do please
don't
turn it off uh latest uh poll says that
uh
probably 20 of us have uh either turned
it off
or deleted it all together we'll have
more on that more on the wild weather
that is really taking on every corner of
the globe
at the moment we'll be telling what's
happening where and
in addition to that some breaking news
that we are receiving from tokyo this
morning
that yet another athlete in the athletes
village has tested positive for covid
so does that mean that their games is
over what does that mean for the other
athletes who are also in the olympic
village
and perhaps for us at home what does
that mean for team
gb will they all manage to stay safe all
of that to come
in just a few moments here on sky news
[Music]
you